dominic cruz joe rogan
yeah they kill it they guess they're the
best yeah
like that's chemistry when the analysis
just the knowledge like okay now he's
gonna like
you know he's gonna swivel his hips he's
gonna he's gonna climb over
who knows what they're watching yeah and
they're so articulate and so
like just impressive i couldn't do that
like a kick and then and then he punched
him four times
i feel like my brother would be uh being
biased and
siding like just subconsciously siding
with people like oh
oh good job or like trying not to coach
people and stuff that's why i would go
wrong especially if you knew them too
yeah yeah exactly it would be like no no
no no sorry
obvious who i was rooting for you're a
super articulate guy and uh
have you thought about getting on the
commentary scene no
no not at all and why is that um
i don't know man i i'd like to act i
like to
use well i think that that's sort of
like you know push in the same boat
i think yeah give it a shot man yeah i
wouldn't be mine i wouldn't mind doing
something like doing like a guest
uh hosting gig or something like that
but for the most part i've always had it
in my heart to
to be in a movie i think my daughter's
really proud
and i think that a little bit of
commentating would like help facilitate
that
you know it's uh in front of the camera
not fighting like
would it be like an action movie would
it be like the notebook
just like essentially
um i could see myself doing something
like a military role to start off just
to get my feet wet you know
being able to wear like a military
uniform and be like an elite
squad member of some still team or
something like that yeah i would love
that you know some real simple
lines for just to start me off and uh
you know i think i i think it'd be right
down my alley yeah
it's always been a dream would you be
worried about though that i i see that
most people that get into acting don't
really do well in their next fight so
would you want to wait till you're done
fighting oh sure
is that fair to say i mean there
is definitely i think a correlation
between people [ __ ] around with
with anything that distracts them and
that's probably a good reason to not
even be worried about the broadcasting
and the commentating
yeah because it's like yo let me keep my
head in the game and not you know
i i i think that uh i think that i would
when i do get into acting i would want
to do it wholeheartedly i'm not
i would like to take like a movie role
like sometime soon just to just to try
like being an extra having a small role
like i was just saying but
to like to actually um pursue it
full time is one i think i'll i'll get
into that when i retire
i want to hire an acting coach and and
do it take the same approach that i've
taken to my mixed martial arts career
and to acting um and with commentary
another reason why
i haven't really tried to pursue
opportunities to get into that and it
could be a subconscious thing
i don't want people to get into my
psychology too much while i'm still an
active fighter
right i feel like if you're smart enough
you could listen to
i always say if you want to know what's
in a man's head you just listen to what
comes out of his mouth and you'll start
to get a true sense
of what's going on in his head right
that's cool so so
so me me explaining the way i see
positions and things like that i think
i'll give people
a little bit of my insight yes exactly
and
i want them to think that it's just my
long arms that makes me win yeah
dude get ready this is going to be
gnarly
pretty gnarly kind of normal are we
ready yeah
what's up denver
[Music]
women can paint their boobs and show
them on instagram
so i figure i should be able to paint my
dick and do whatever i want
make some noise for my brother
[Applause]
wait let me inspect for crabs this time
[Music]
when my buddies lit that stuff right
away i knew
i [ __ ] up
[Music]
i'm not doing this to hurt your dad
you're not gonna hurt me you're gonna
piss me off